hello everybody hope they are good maybe
this is catching you by surprise it's
been a long time to be honest but daily
videos are coming back from today so
Monday to Friday you can expect a daily
video analyzing the price action of
Bitcoin we'll go through some trade
setups and my thoughts about uh the
current uh situation of the chart but I
also recommend you joining the free
telegram channel that uh I've created
recently um during this time that I've
been traveling and I've been busy with
all Investments real estate other
project so um I've been also posting in
that channel some tips some altcoin
charts a lot of Al coins to be honest
that we've traded so um I recommend you
join in there because it's going to be
active uh too okay of course X or
Twitter it's going to be active but uh I
think that the YouTube channel is going
to be a big thing for us this year
because it's a good way to communicate
and uh basically to talk about the chart
sometimes uh text is not enough you know
so we're going to go through through the
charts every day first of all daily time
frame what do I see here well I mean
we've been going up since basically um
this consolidation Zone because to be
honest this was kind of a range here cuz
if you mark this okay like this you can
see how this was clearly arrange yes you
have some uh traps for example you have
a here trap to the upside another one
here okay but pretty much this was a
range you can see that that was sideways
okay then we got some expansion and this
looks quite similar to me okay this is
another range so if we mark it actually
I'm going to go to the forward time
frame it's be easier to mark this U this
range okay you're going to notice how
this is another range here okay so if we
do this that's the range
highs and I'm going to Mark the range
lows
here okay okay you can see how this is
another range of course we had some
traps again we've had a small trap here
this was a strange uh there was some
kind of a short squeeze here and they
pushed price to 49k but again this are
just deviations same as this okay and
you can see how you know this is
essentially a range and we are inside
right now so that's the structure that
we are currently in it's a range guys
okay and this can be quite choppy
especially for swing Traders typical
trading here would be too short the
local well the the range highs and too
long the the range slows but again it
works
sometimes sometimes no because if you
short here you probably get stop okay
this obviously you get stop this if you
long here you're going to get stop again
so that's not something that I always
recommend okay instead when I see a
range
um I'm only looking for imbalances
because in a Range that is sideways
price action price is naturally going to
go to fill some imbalances okay so
that's what I'm aiming for okay I'm only
looking for imbalances in a Range that's
how I trade ranges pretty much okay what
imbalances do I see well there are two
types of imbalances uh mainly I mean
there are many but the two that I like
the most in the charts are weeks and
liquidity pool so uh the first first of
all I see a long week here at the highs
uh
49k and the 50% of the week is around I
would say
48k okay that's the 50% of the week why
do I Mark the 50% of the week the guys
in the course now but price tends to get
rejected also at the 50% of the week it
doesn't necessarily need to go to the
100% okay it can go to the 50% get
rejected and then we'll consider that
week to be failed because he has gone at
least the 50% of it okay so that's the
first imbalance the way to the upside
now we're going to look for liquidity
pools I see a few liquidity pools um I
like this one something fell there
usually happens in the videos I don't
know why I drop things okay that is a
liquidity pool here this long candle
here okay and to the upsite I see
another liquidity pull and it would be
this one here okay that it's a
combination really of these two large
red candles right so these are the two
liquidity pools that I in the chart
those are the imbalances the price is
going to try to go to okay now the order
is what is complex is going to go first
towards the liquidity pool to the
downside or are we want to go up from
here go and fill this liquidity pool and
also this week all right that is what is
the most difficult part but the first
thing is that you have to um Mark the
the imbalances as you see in the chat
all right so um I'm going to take some
quick notes here so we all can see
all right those are the balances that I
see so seeing this chart I will tell you
that the you mean look at the size of
this liquidity pool versus this
liquidity pool this liquidity pool is
larger and also we have a week to the
upside so I would say right now that the
liquidity is mainly to the upside we're
going to check now the order book we're
going to check the liquidation heat map
and we're going to try to see if it's
matching what I see in the chart with
those external tools okay so let's
go this is the other book and we can see
some red bars to the upsite at
43,500 and
44,000 what does this mean okay the
order book is basically showing you the
orders that Traders place in the
exchange these orders are going to be
limit orders buy and sell limit orders
in this case the red bars are to the
upsite so they are going to be sell
orders okay if they are um either buy or
sell limit orders they going to be sell
orders in this case now the thing is
that the order book he only shows limit
orders and a limit order is also a take
profits an stop loss A liquidation and
with the order book you don't know which
thing is okay this can be a a stop- loss
A liquidation or a sell limit order okay
it could be a sell world you don't know
the book the order book is basically
telling us right now that there is more
liquidity to the upsite so that's
already giving you a little clue that
maybe the chart is going to favor higher
prices okay so that's the first clue the
other book is saying higher prices at
the moment also you can see by the at
42k there is some liquidity but less
okay it's less to the downside than to
the than to the upside so mainly the
liquidity is to the upsite we are on h
capital and I want to check the
liquidations okay in the one month time
frame so this is basically going to tell
me that in the previous 30 days okay all
the positions open in the previous 30
days days where are those liquidations
of those positions are they to the
upside or to the downside basically I
just want to know where the liquidity is
okay I have Lo capitalist telling me
that those liquidations are to the
upsite at
44,800 so could we say that the
liquidity that we saw in the order book
at 44k are liquidations I would say so
okay because you have the Confluence of
h capital telling you that at that same
place there is a good amount of
liquidations right um so remember in the
other book you saw some liquidity at
44,000 and
43,500 44,000 is liquidations now we're
going to go into the 7 Days time frame
but the one month time frame is saying
the same as other book The liquidity is
to the upsite we should favor higher
prices okay 7 Days time frame I check
this chart earlier and I can tell you
that it's a mess at the moment because
we can see liquidations to the upsite
between
43,700 and also
44,500 so that's around uh pretty much
$900
$800 difference that's a lot of a big
area to be honest so that's not telling
me that much information okay yes there
is there is liquidity uh there are
liquidations between
43,6 and 44,000 something okay the same
that matches with the other book the
other book was saying 44
43,500 I think so there could be also
liquidations okay but to the downside
this can be a a bit misleading okay
because to the downside there is also a
lot of liquidations a
41,45 4 1,300 so this is what you have
to be careful with okay if you remove
this area here and imagine that this
chart doesn't say that they are
liquidity to the downside then you could
say okay
there is not much reason for price to go
down price should go up straight away
because that's where the liquidity is in
the market okay to the upsite but we
have this Zone here that I don't like
there is there could be a reason for for
price to go down at the moment okay and
it's because there are some liquidations
here and why are there some liquidations
to the upside and to the downside too
well basically because this is a range
of consolidation okay people are just
pulling their bets
uh and sometimes people go into the
chart like if they're in a casino okay
so um some people are going to go long
some people are going to go short people
also read the charts differently so um
there is liquidity to hunt in both sides
so that's the part that we have to be
very careful with okay but I just wanted
to show you this how I read the chart
and if we check the the liquidations hit
maps and the order book mainly the
liquidity is to the upsite but there
could be an intense to drop price lower
first okay that's pretty much what I saw
what I said two days ago in the in the
Bitcoin to the update okay so uh we're
going to go back to the Chart we're
going to make some projections and some
ideas for trading Okay so we've
collected all the information that we
didn't have before from the order book
and from the liquidation hit map now
we're back in the chart I'm we have to
try to make sense of what we've seen
okay we have to try to make sense of all
the information and use it for or
trading setup so uh first of all I also
wanted to point out this potential
support that I'm seeing here um I also
pointed this out in the Bitcoin soon
theate on on X on Twitter and is this
Zone over here okay I'm going to change
the color to gray you can see how price
um stopped in this area here here too
also here we continue and this continues
okay more
here okay well that's basically l 1 2 3
4 so that's quite a good so a good
support to be honest okay um what I mean
with this is that um if price drops here
it doesn't necessarily need to go to the
range lows it can just go to this
support here at
40,700 and bounce from here okay it
would partially retrace this liquidity
pull of course it can go lower go to the
range lows and then it would retrace
pretty much the entire liquidity pool
that would also be good but what I mean
is that don't try to place your bit if
you're going to place on buy orders
don't place them all at the exact you
know range lows don't place them at
4,321 35 why because maybe it goes to
4,740 and it bounces from there so uh if
you are planning to go long from the
range lows it's ALS always better to
diversify those orders okay split them
into small orders you can have more
orders so you mean maybe you maybe maybe
three or four long orders get fail and 3
do but at least you are partially in the
trade okay sometimes you might otherwise
get out of the trade for a few cents and
that's quite sad so uh that's what I
wanted to point out that's support that
I like there now I want to take you to
the 8 hours time frame 50 Ma you want to
see what I mean why the a hours I want
you to check it the 50
Ma you see how it's
respecting this moving average here
support support support support support
we are currently above support okay now
if you check here also back in this into
this range support support support
support a bit of resistance resistance
back it support support support okay now
if you go to the 4 time frame that's
usually the chart well the time frame
that I would use this you know this um
50 m is not respecting it that well so
that's why I like to Adu it sometimes to
the 8 hours time frame when I can see it
more clear all right so we're going to
play with the 8 hours time frame
15ma right now it's sitting
at
42520 okay and we above support which
means that you know it potentially we
could directly Bounce from here okay and
just go higher so that's one thing to
consider we can go into uh lower time
frame to try to see if we can see
something else at that Z and I do okay I
can see also this liquidity pool
here that's another liquidity pool that
is matching exactly at
42,500 okay so what I want to say with
this is that it's possible that price
bounces from here already and goes to
fill well to retrace his liquidity pool
and fills this week so what I would do
is this is my plan okay again it's not
Financial
advice only use this as Confluence to
the Chart don't trade based on this so
I'm only telling you my uh my opinion
about the chart so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to try to do to take a
small long a small size here okay if we
come to the 8 hour 50 again I'll take a
a small long okay uh with this small
size and I'm going to aim for this
liquidity pool Okay then if we see some
consolidation here then it's possible
that we go and fill this week to the
upside all right now if we close a
Candlestick below the 8 hours 50 Ma and
in the next one or the next ones cuz it
might be in the with one candle or two
three four candles we are testing it as
resistance the 50 ma in the 8 hours time
frame that is telling me to get out of
that small long okay change to a
short aim towards this support here this
liquidity pull range lows whatever you
want I'm going to if that happens I'm
going to take most of my profits at this
support here
40,700 okay and then here is what I'm
going to diversify my long orders okay
and I'm going to start from
40,700 all the way down to 4 $4,000 so
that's $700 of basically building a long
position okay maybe we can see something
like this and a fast recovery to the
upside that's what I'm seeing in the
chart I hope that was clear okay so
basically if price drops towards this
area here perfect because that's the
area I want to go long from okay I want
to go long from this area however price
might Bounce from here because you are
also above support so I'm going to take
take a very small size long here okay in
case we Bounce from here cuz I don't
want to miss that move but if we close
candles below the 50 May 8 hours time
frame that small trade is invalidated I
flip to a short I aim for these range
lows this support this liquidity pool
and then here I built my long position
for price to go back up it's as simple
as that uh this might not happen today
it might not happen tomorrow it might
take a few days because the chart is
quite slow at the moment
but that's essentially what I'm looking
at okay uh so I hope that was clear then
um I I basically agree with what the
what external tuns we've been looking at
say because I've seen it also in the
chart I've seen this week I've seen this
with it pull the other book tells me 44k
and
43,500 the liquidation hit map tells me
44,00 so yes the liquidity is to the
upside we should see some some we should
see a move up before before leaving this
range okay now do I think we're want to
break up from this range or break down
from the range I personally think that
it'll be nice to test this area again
here okay we might teste this area again
here around 36k so yes I think that it's
more likely we'll see because with the
high time frame sometimes it's more
difficult for me but I would lean more
towards a breakdown from this range here
okay but first I would like to see some
recovery of these zones to the upside
and that's what I'm Trading all right so
I hope that was clear I hope that was
clear for our first video um if you like
it then I've never said this but click
the like button and I'll see you
tomorrow guys with our new update so
thank you so much for watching see you
soon